this is Grand Master Daniel nerdinski we
are watching Magnus Carlson taking on
rehard report at the 2022 fide World
Blitz championship and Magnus starts the
game with 1d4 and Richard offers a
transposition to the French which Magnus
Carlson accepts what variation of the
French are we going to get Bishop to B4
this is the win hour variation it is the
most popular response to Knight C3 and
now we have a trade on C3 now the center
in these lines is incredibly closed
generally black pushes that c Pawn down
to C4 at some point and the center
becomes completely locked white starts
playing on the king side black starts
playing on the queen side we are going
to get an old school Barn burger here as
Magnus shoves this Pawn up to H4
grabbing space on the king side and
there goes the pawn up to H5 Richard
prevents its progress by playing H6 you
don't want to let white go H6 in these
types of positions and weaken the dark
Square complex on the king side the
players continuing to develop their
pieces the bishop coming out to be five
with check and now dropping back to D3
Magnus making sure that he keeps his
Bishop pair alive and there is that C4
move Richard takes the opportunity to
play the move with Tempo now establishes
a bishop onto A4 the idea of that move
is to prevent white from pushing the
pawn up to A4 and opening up a beautiful
developing Square on A3 for his dark
scored bishop and Magnus is going to
have to decide where he wants his dark
scored Bishop to live it's essentially
hemmed in by all of White Center pawns
maybe he wants to put it on F4 and offer
further support for the E5 pawn and
that's exactly what he does Bishop
coming out to F4 and Report completes
his minor piece development with Knight
to A6 kind of an unconventional move
maybe later on once the queen moves away
from C7 Richard wants to dial that
Knight back around to C7 and then maybe
to B5 and put pressure on White's King
side black castling Queen side and the
queen side is a very safe place to be
for Black's King because it's so hard
for white to open up that Queen side the
a file is totally blocked by that
monster Bishop on A4 King B7 by report
Magnus circling back to F1 with his
Knight now forward he goes to E3 that
night nicely centralized and maybe there
will one day be a sack on C4 but it's
way too early to talk about sacrifices
neither side really has anything going
as of yet and Pritchard has been playing
at lightning speed he is up a full
minute on the clock he still has three
minutes on the clock all of the time
that he started with and he continues to
play at Breakneck speed 97 to C6 goes
report bringing more beef to the king
side and Magnus he's playing it slow
pushing the pawn up to G3 probably
preparing to tuck his King away on G2
and make sure that his Rooks are
connected now eventually black might try
something like G7 G5 or even F7 F6 white
can play on the king side but black can
also play on the king side especially
since White's King is now parked on G2
and I think Richard is starting to do
just that Queen E8 to GA that Queen
could kind of feel keto itself on H7 to
put more pressure on C2 or it could
support a push of the Jeep on and Magnus
continues to fall behind on the clock as
you can see him they're nervously
fiddling with the only Pawn that he has
captured thus far no that's a bishop he
hasn't captured any pawns the position's
still very locked up as he moves this
Rook up to B1 and indeed report putting
his Queen on that very safe H7 Square as
it aims at the C2 Pawn Magnus though his
Bishops now look kind of imposing the
bishop on F3 is x-raying the King on B7
and don't fall asleep on a potential
night sacrifice on C4 in order to open
that diagonal up Black's Bishop on A4 is
very nicely placed but it's also kind of
hemmed in by the Knight on c6's report
carefully brings his King back to B8 but
Knight takes C4 almost Works after d
takes C4 the bishop on A4 actually
defends the Knight on C6 so it's not
possible just yet Magnus is down a full
minute and 15 seconds as he moves his
Queen down to E2 kind of a cagey old
school closed Center fight both players
posturing four position and in these
types of positions you want to make sure
that you are prepared when the center
actually opens up and it's likely to
open up eventually because the players
they don't have infinite patience but
who is going to strike first who is
going to initiate the first battle and
finally the Hungarian Grandmaster takes
a prolonged think as he moves his Rook
from d8 to C8 he's just trying to make
sure that his ranks are buttressed on
the on the queen side that his Knights
are fully protected and Magnus he is
making motions to attack on the queen
side Rook to B2 preparing to double his
Rooks on the B file maybe even a rook
sacrifice on B6 is possible everything
is possible in these types of positions
by the Knight it jumps out to B5 and
that's a fork on two of magnus's Pawns
but the A3 Pawn is largely Untouchable
because the Rook will slide from H1 to
A1 and pin Black's minor pieces on the a
file but Magnus there he goes Knight
takes D5 and we have our first sacrifice
of the game we have waited patiently
with one minute on the clock Magnus
grabs the pawn on D5 and he might want
to play E6 check and open up a discover
check on Black's King let's see what he
does yes indeed there goes the e-pawn
now his Bishops are open and the light
light squared Bishop can jump into the
action with a capture on D5 but first
Magnus takes on F7 and he has two pawns
for the sacrifice piece a monster upon
an F7 and a prospect of capturing on D5
but he might have missed that response
Queen H7 jumps out to F5 it defends D5
it attacks F7 report for the time being
keeping everything protected can Magnus
find a way to add fuel to the fire he
really doesn't want to go Bishop G4 he
can win back the exchange but that
Bishop is worth its weight in gold
speaking of gold what a move by Magnus
he sacks another rook and he does that
in order to vacate the path to E7
pushing Black's King to an incredibly
vulnerable Square the king moves up to
A6 and Magnus is now currently down a
rook and a piece he's going to recapture
the Knight on B4 and he does so with his
Queen but now the bishop on A4 it's
finally vulnerable it's under attack and
if you lose the bishop you also lose the
Knight but the bishop it's so slippery
it captures on C2 Magnus playing a full
Rook down but Black's King is on the
cusp of getting checkmated the night
drops back to C7 seven Magnus with 35
seconds on his clock a rook down report
he doesn't seem to believe it he kind of
raises his eyebrows calling the world
champions Bluff Magnus captures the
Knight on C7 and now oh the bishop drops
back to F4 report did not recapture he
instead targets the bishop on F3 and now
he can win The Rook on H1 with a check
on e4 Will he win that rook in the
corner and will his King survive the
after aftermath Magnus has a potentially
devastating check that he can deliver on
the B5 Square driving the king back to
B7 and then he might have another check
on D7 but report he doesn't buy it
there's the check on e4 and a little
hesitation as he captures The Rook on H1
this is unbelievable the world champion
is down a rook and an exchange and he
keeps attacking as if nothing's the
matter he pushes his Pawn to A5 he plays
quietly down 10 points in material A4 A5
threatening to drive the pawn up to A6
and lock Black's King in the corner on
A8 and it's important to notice that
White's King on G4 is actually really
quite safe Black's rocks have no open
files to operate on so in a way White's
attacking Firepower outweighs what
Richard report has even though he's a
full rook in an exchange up and now the
Hungarian Grandmaster drops to 53
seconds on the clock you can see the
signs of anxiety if there goes the pawn
up to A6 it goes and I think Magnus
might have been able to play F3 there
and then promote it to a queen and
captured on T5 but that opportunity was
missed instead he sacrifices his F Bond
and drives his Queen to D7 a counter
sacrifice on F4 and Richard report has
succeeded in finally breaching the gates
now he's got a bunch of Queen checks
Queen G2 check he's got a Perpetual if
he wants it he does have a Perpetual
check if he wants it Queen takes F2
check he can continue checking on G2 and
F2 because Magnus is King it cannot go
up to F5 it will get skewered on H3 and
he's got exactly one attacking piece
left he cannot give up his Queen by any
means and another check on G2 will the
Hungarian Grandmaster accept the draw he
takes his time he can even and think
until he's got one second left queen H2
check is a draw he has another check
with a pawn and he fearlessly goes G5
check he sacks upon and I think he's
done that in order to play H5 the king
is driven up to G5 or will it move back
to F3 Carlson zigzagging and Meandering
and trying to escape the wrath of the
black queen and he grabs his King he
hasn't released it yet and now he does
King F3 is his decision and another
check on H1 report still has a Perpetual
check in his pocket but clearly he wants
more Carlson down to 14 seconds King
back to F2 and another check this time
on H4 and report he could force a queen
trade on G4 if he wants to but that's
not the end of the story he will be a
rook up in an end game but Carlson will
have two menacing connected pass pawns
we could get a pawn race with reports
sending his beep on down the board that
would be crazy and we're gonna get it
Queen G4 check report continues to play
for a win and there go the pawns B5 F5
B4 F6 who will promote first they might
promote at the same time white might end
up with two Queens on the board and this
this is insane this is impossible to
calculate both players down to 20
seconds B take C3 by report there goes
magnus's F Bond and now his Jeep on and
you never say this but which Queen is
Magnus going to make he makes the queen
on f8 oh G8 Queen would have been met
with Queen G1 check and now we're gonna
get another series of crazy checks Queen
G1 check by report where is Magnus going
to go he has to go to the H file he
cannot go to the f file he's gonna get
skewered on F2 and the King continues to
zigzag King G6 I still think report has
a Perpetual check if he wants it but if
he doesn't take it he could very well
get mated if he's not careful with that
King on A8 is still Boxed In by The Pawn
on A6 that's the unsung hero of White's
attack more checks on H4 and on G4 five
seconds by Magnus King H6 another
implicit draw for and again report goes
for it with C3 and Magnus with two
seconds on the clock he's got to move
his Queen back and he threatens made on
B7 oh my goodness there's a mate thread
on B7 there's a May threat on D5 report
circles his Queen Round toward the
center Magnus drops back to G5 more
checks with the black queen this time
report checking on the diagonal Magnus
with two seconds on the clock as he made
that move Queen E8 oh but he blunder GA
Queen oh my goodness Magnus makes the
second Queen and if report captures it
he gets checkmated on B7 Magnus might
win this game report has to start
checking again but this time with two
Queens on the board white might actually
escape the checks rookie Shake King G5
the king is sheltered by one of White's
queens and the other Queen is gonna do
the checkmating I think Magnus is going
to win King up to F6 reporters running
out of tracks Black's Queen is driven
back the king moves up to E7 there's
still a mate thread on C on D5 and queen
G8 check leads to a back rank Checkmate
Magnus leans back in disbelief he has
won the game and what a game it was you
can see laughter from both players there
and if you enjoyed this incredible game
make sure to click the link in the
playlist for more of these videos thank
you for watching
foreign